Maxime et juriste c'est son surnom
doivent traverser ce terrain marécageux
car de l'autre côté il y a le corps d'un
soldat russe
les deux hommes dystenir grâce à
l'esprit de camaraderie car le travail
est sinistre il ramasse des cadavres
disséminés dans la région de Rachid
après un kilomètre nous atteignons le
but
on est venu ici avant et on a pris tous
les corps qu'on pouvait transporter
maintenant revient pour le cinquième
comme vous voyez il n'en reste pas
grand-chose il était blessé il a des
gares aux jambes il y a seulement la
moitié du corps c'est sans doute des
chiens qui ont mangé l'autre moitié où
l'on emporté ailleurs
[Musique]
avec les premiers corps qu'on a trouvé
bien sûr que ça m'a fait quelque chose
comme tout le monde
mais après en avoir transporté une
centaine ou plus et ça me fait plus rien
on est prêt à échanger tous les corps
qu'on trouve contre ceux des nôtres et
vraiment je supplie leurs proches de
mettre en place un mouvement de
protestation
[Musique]
l'espoir c'est que l'opinion russe
réalise à quel point les pertes sont
importantes et que le soutien pour la
guerre diminue
bien sûr si ces hommes récupèrent les
corps c'est surtout pour les échanger
contre des dépouilles de soldats
Ukrainiens mais c'est aussi pour éviter
la pollution de l'environnement et pour
collecter des preuves qui pourront
servir lors de futurs procès pour crime
de guerre d'abord on les amène à la mort
et après les procédures d'identification
on les charge dans les wagons
dans cette voiture deux chemins de fer
une dizaine de cordes soldats russes
ils seront échangés dans les jours qui
viennent
ce que je ressens vis-à-vis de
rien
ce sont des cadavres c'est tout une
chose
juriste déjà récupéré plus de 400
cadavres russes et rien que dans la
région rare qui nous reste encore des
centaines à trouver